andrée lamontagne ministres de
l'agriculture du québec bonsoir monsieur
la montagne sur votre physique quand
votre homologue madame by bozzi nous
poussons très fort pour arriver à une
entente dans les meilleurs délais est ce
que c'est assez pour vous ça non c'est
certainement pas assez puis aussi il
faut savoir que l'avis de grève a été
déposé le 16 novembre puis qu'on en soit
là aujourd'hui le 25 novembre se demande
à quel point les gens sont pas
conscients de la réalité des résultats
sur le terrain
vous pensez donc le gouvernement fédéral
devra lit plus plus vite et plus loin
est allé jusqu'à la loi spéciale aurait
dû déjà été engagés on devrait sentier
qui se passe quelque chose ce terrain
les échos qu'on a ce qui se passe rien
les gens le fédéral ne mets pas de
pression
la loi spéciale c'est un chemin mais je
suis ça fait déjà une semaine la grève
est déclenchée puis comme dit la vie
grève est envoyée le 16 novembre qui ont
aucun geste qui était posé son arme
était conscient de l'impact - des pour
les gens super n y aurait des gens qui
auraient allumé le piquet aurait posé
des gestes avant sol vous de votre côté
vous pouvez faire quoi il vous fait quoi
au gouvernement du québec
nous ce qu'on fait là c'est comme mon
collègue des mines et énergie l'un en
parle encore cet après midi là on écume
le québec qui on est comme toutes les
possibilités pour tourner toutes les
pierres pour aller s'approvisionner peut
être capable d'amener dans le fond ce
qu'on veut c'est gagner des jours parce
qu'on sait qu'on est en situation de
rationnement on a besoin 2.5 millions de
litres par jour là dessus en un parti
qui va pleut monde agricole alors ce
qu'on cherche à faire dans un premier
temps c'est de gagner des journées mais
ce qu'on veut éviter c'est que le
gouvernement fédéral s'assoit sur ces
efforts là que l'on fait pour aller
tirer aller chercher une journée après
l'autre pour laisser un conflit s'étire
et se tirer puis pas prendre pour
prendre soin finalement des gens super
et mais compte tenu de l'urgence de la
situation de la gravité de la situation
des problèmes des agriculteurs qui
existait déjà en raison du temps froid
dd défense tout ce qu'ont eu la neige
peu après cela publie pile humidité puis
tous les problèmes
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à aider
financièrement les agriculteurs mais
votre écoute et déjà au départ moi j'ai
demandé la financière agricole la
semaine passée de mettre en place une
cellule de crise et à plusieurs leviers
sont en place déjà pour venir en aide
aux producteurs aux différentes
productions il ya des avis de dommages
qui doit être déposé mais c'est certain
que nous
notre objectif dans tout seul c'est en
sus des programmes sont en place c'est
de s'assurer d'être en soutien le pont
nos jeunes vous rencontrer les
producteurs de grains demain oui je
rencontre demain les producteurs de
grains les céréaliers du québec je les
rencontre je suis était en discussion
avec lui la semaine passée ils
producteurs laitiers courte fédérer les
agriculteurs leurs chants tous les jours
je tends communication que ces gens là
vous allez leur dire quoi demain ben on
va prendre acte 1 dollar de l'heure de
leurs revendications et aussi des
affirmations qui vont nous faire
et puis on va partager sur des portraits
nous on a des portraits peu à jour le
des niveaux de récolte que j'ai eu il ya
quelques minutes la à la grandeur du
québec on va partager avec eux qu'est ce
qu'ils en aient quels sont les besoins
et carnets mais qu'est ce qui a nui au
moment où on se parle dépendamment des
régions mais on va peut-être de 30% dry
cote à peu près 60 et 10 pour celles qui
étaient récoltées l'an passé à la même
date on parlait dans 70 s à 98% qui
avaient été récoltés compris qu'un écart
considérable un écart considérable à des
pertes considérables et déjà il ya une
semaine avant même la grève du cn les
producteurs de grains disait ça nous
prend une haine parce que l'assurance
récolte via une franchise de 20 % donc
20% sur 750 millions c'est 150 millions
qui doivent assumer
d'une part et ils ont donc besoin de
plusieurs dizaines de millions $ ce sont
les mots de monsieur legault ici est ce
que vous êtes prêt à vous engager à un
soutien financier supplémentaire de
plusieurs dizaines de millions 20 dans
un premier temps ce qui était important
monsieur fillion le ce qu'on parle de
ces cas l'assurance récolte on parle d
agri on parlait gré à gré investissement
d agri stabilité alors il ya un ensemble
de programmes qui sont là pour venir
soutenir mir protéger les marges mais
chose qui est sûre c'est qu'elle bilan
de tout se refaire c'est certain qu'on
va s'asseoir avec eux pour vous regardez
l'ampleur de ce qu'on va avoir vécu mais
est ce qu'il faut faire des bilans
s'asseoir éventuellement où il n'y a pas
une urgence maintenant tout à fait s'il
ya des besoins au niveau de débourser
des liquidités encore il ya des
mécanismes qui sont en place pour
pouvoir le faire mais on s'entend aussi
faut qu'ils aient des avis de dommages
qu'ils soient déposées par les gens pour
qu'on soit mesure de mesurer l'ampleur
de tout seul quels contacts vous avez
eue avec le ministre garneau
la ministre bibeau dans les derniers
jours le ministre garneau de ce contact
j'ai eu c'est quand j'ai écouté les
nouvelles vendredi soir puis j'ai vu que
pour lui c'est un peu business as usual
la sauge thym est vraiment vraiment
désespérée tout ça madame di buono
convenu de se parler le ce soir vers 20h
le jouet parle avec elle je lui parlais
la semaine passée après son
assermentation la prestation de serment
tension ne parler de la situation qui
prévalait déjà mais ce soir ce sera 20
ans le jeune homme entretenir avec elle
la mais j'ai attendu un peu ses
déclarations ce matin un sens qu'on
cherche une solution négociée
est-ce que vous ai fait des jeux d
évaluation des pertes de récoltes
non honnêtement j'ai pas j'ai pas ces
chiffres là par contre chez la
financière qui va travailler financiers
agricoles il votre avis sur ce dossier
là demain on va voir les représentations
le des producteurs de grains et puis ce
travail qu'on va faire le bien mais
c'est la montagne merci beaucoup pour
cet entretien qui on va suivre bien sûr
cette rencontre avec les producteurs de
grains de demain andrée lamontagne
ministre de l'agriculture merci merci
monsieur fillon
bonsoir